Suck on a fish head lollipop
and chew bubble gum shaped like butt cheeks.
It's episode 24
of LÜT.
Vat19's chameleon lamp detects
the color of the surface
it's on and glows that color.
You can also turn your iPhone into a
laser pointer with an app
and a smart dot that plugs right into
the headphone jack.
But what has even more energy than a laser?
That's right,
Vsauce t-shirts.
The official team jerseys
of Wesaucers everywhere, for boys and girls.
We just launched this store.
If you get one and where it to VidCon,
reward yourself with cookies cut into
Pacman shapes
or just march the shapes down Abbey Road.
Busted Tees has more apparel designs.
You can twist nerdy
brains with "Similes are like metaphors,"
or my favorite, Helvetiva written in Comic
Sans.
Or the first true
digital cowboy.
Busted Tees also offers
bookends? Well, this one makes it look like
your books are about to squish a guy.
Knob Creek Metal Arts makes even more.
Chainsaws, giraffes, mermaids,
abductions and more.
Butt
magnets, animal butt magnets.
Are you trying to carry stuff more often?
Well, TheCheeky brings you glasses you can't set
down. They have no flat bottom,
so they'll spill if you try to put them down.
Now, this amazingly intricate chocolate
temple is even more
intricately wrapped in silver foil.
But here's an even better idea.
Make hard things soft.
These pillows
photo realistically reproduce
textures like plywood and concrete, but if
you prefer
be musical with boombox pillows
and keep it cute with glasses that give you anime eyes.
Of course, these glasses make it look
like someone's got their
hands over your eyes, but I prefer to shade
my sight with a country.
The USA.
Now, you don't really need glasses when it's rainy,
but how will you write on paper?
Easy, with write in the rain - special
waterproof paper
that a pencil will always write on,
especially if you sharpen it inside the nostril
of a nose pencil sharpener.
When the Sun comes back out,
this iPad case will charge the iPad in
it using solar power.
But even without the Sun,
sprout bookmarks make it look like
life and leaves are springing from your novels.
Novels you store on
invisible shelves.
The special peace holds 15 pounds of book,
but hides inside the bottom book,
so they appear to float
in the air. Now, back to leaves.
If you get leaves like spinach and other junk stuck in
your teeth after eating,
fear no more with a mirror in a plate.
Once you're done eating you reveal
a mirror to check your teeth.
You can look beyond your own face and into space
with ThinkGeek's space-y serving bowls - the Moon,
the Sun and Earth.
For the kids or yourself,
I like this landscape dinner set.
A Sun cup,
a house plate, evergreen utensils and a cloud bowl.
Now, if the food on the plate is bland,
season it with salt and pepper from
shakers shaped like
Fred and Daphne, Shaggy and Scooby,
Kermit and Miss Piggy
or fozzie bear and a banana peel.
You can precisely
warm your now seasoned dishes in the
oven with this magnetic
timer that makes your fridge look like a safe.
Or just use a watch that is a giant
10-key number pad. ThinkGeek also offers
a chocolate-scented t-shirt featuring
a chocolate molecule from Theobroma cacao.
Even sweeter is upgrading your unsightly mudflap girls
with these smart mudflaps girls.
Now jam to some tunes played out of your Marshall
amp.
Just kidding, it's a mini fridge full of
beers you can open with the jaws of a brain-hungry
zombie. If zombies scare you,
try using a night light shaped like a creature
trying to
unplug itself.
Or, light your way with this
USB powered lamp that looks like a cup
of melty chocolate
pouring all over.
But if you need more USB ports,
Fred Flare offers this cute little poodle USB
hub.
You can turn any photo into a hip retro
polaroid with these polar frames.
And stop flicking your wrist
to tell the time with this watch.
It's tilted 55 degrees,
so it lines up with the natural way you
hold your arms
in front of you.
Now, earlier this week I was in Munich
at Frühlingsfest where I successfully saw
historical things,
ferris wheel things, ate a half meter long sausage
and met Bernd das Brot.
I got water on my glasses, because it hailed.
I did get a giant pretzel...
And as always,
thanks for watching.